[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم نشرت كتائب عز الدين القسام
الجناح العسكري لحركه المقاومه الاسلاميه
حماس صور اربعه اسرائيليين لديها وقال ابو
عبيده المتحدث باسم الكتائب ان تل ابيب لن
تحصل على اي معلومه عن مصير هؤلاء الار
ما لم تدفع اثمان واضحه نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي الرسائل التي ارادت حماس
توجيهها من خلال الاعلان عن وجود هؤلاء
الاسرائيليين
لديها وكيف تتفاعل القصه في اسرائيل خاصه
تاثيرها على حكومه
نتنياهو هل هم احياء ام اموات ومتى وقعوا
في يد حماس الجناح العسكري للحركه كتائب
عز الدين القسام تجنب الخوض في التفاصيل
المتعلقه بهؤلاء الاسرائيليين الاربعه
الذين قال انهم لديه ولن تحصل تل ابيب على
اي معلومه عنهم الا بمقابل ثمين المتحدث
باسم القسام نفى وجود اي اتصالات حتى الان
مع اسرائيل بهذا الصدد لكنه على ما يبدو
لا يغلق الباب امام مفاوضات محتمله قد
تعود الى الاذان صفقه جلع شليط عام
2011 تقرير فاطمه
التريكي فما الذي تخبئه وحده الظل في
قبضتها هؤلاء هم الافصاح بعد التلميح الذي
خرج قبل شهرين اربعه دفعه واحده كشف عن
صورهم المتحدث العسكري باسم كتائب القسام
ابو عبيد
وقال ان الوجوه فقط هي ما ستعرفه اسرائيل
واي شيء اخر له ثمن الرساله الثانيه لذوي
الجنود نتنياهو يكذب عليكم لا توجد ايه
اتصالات او مفاوضات حتى الان حول جنود
العدو الاسرى وان ايه معلومات عن مصير
هؤلاء الجنود الاربعه لن يحصل عليها العدو
الا عبر دفع استحقاقات واثمان
واضحه بنيامين نتنياهو كان قال الاحد
الماضي ان قضيه المفقودين خلال الحرب
الاسرائيليه الاخيره على غزه عام
2014 تشهد تطورات وعليه فان اعلان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه كذب ذلك يمثل فضلا عن
وقعه العسكري هزه معنويه وسياسيه للاحتلال
وحكومته وجمهوره وهو الذي يحرص على شفافيه
في تعامله مع هذا الجمهور عامان الا قليلا
من الترقب والحيره اذا لم تنفع معها قدرات
اسرائيل الاستخباراتيه المعروفه في الحصول
على اي معلومه اذ لم تحسم حركه حماس مصير
الجنديين شاؤول ارون وهاد جولدن الذين
تعترف اسرائيل بانهما فقدا في المعارك
وذلك سبق من قبل في حاله جلع شليط الذي ظل
مخفيا من عام 2006 حتى
201 واطلقت باسمه حروب ولم يطلق الا
بمبادىء فلسطينيين الامر المتوقع على نطاق
اوسع في الحاله الرباعيه الجديده الا ان
ذلك كله يفتح الباب على الحلقه الاكبر
التي تقود الى اصل المشكله فالاس سرعان ما
يحل مكانهم اسرى جدد خلال الشهر الماضي
فقط اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال
647 فلسطينيا بينهم عشرات الاطفال والنساء
بما يجعل الحل الناجز براي كثر مستندين
الى شواهد الواقع في مقاومه الاحتلال وبكل
وسيله لكن في فلسطين من يرى غير ذلك الامن
عندنا يدخل المدارس ليفتش في المدارس شنط
الاولاد اذا فيها سكاكين ام لا الرئيس
الفلسطيني يقول ان الحل في اتمام انسحاب
اسرائيل من الضفه واستمرار التنسيق الامني
التنسيق الذي يقود بدوره الى اعتقال
مقاومين وبهذا المعنى فان المواقف لا تكشف
عن نهجين مت ين في مقاربه واقع الاحتلال
بل عن تناقد ينتهي فعليا بزياده في الاسرى
الفلسطينيين مع ما يستدعيه ذلك من اسر
مضاد مكلف وشاق
لاطلاق نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من غزه
الكاتب والباحث السياسي مصطفى الصواف من
رام الله هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات
لابحاث السياسات ومن الناصره الدكتور
محمود يزبك استاذ الدراسات الشرق اوسطيه
في جامعه حيفا نبدا بالسيد مصطفى الوافي
في غزه ما الذي ارادته حماس من خلال هذا
الاعلان بعد طول
انتظار مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك الكرام
اعتقد ان فتح هذا الموضوع الان هو محاوله
من قبل القسام للتاثير اولا على الجبهه
الداخليه الاسرائيليه وكذلك في محاوله
لطرق الباب حت حتى يتم بدايه حديث حول
تبادل الاسرى ثم هي رساله الى الاسرى
الفلسطين داخل سجون الاحتلال تطمئنهم بان
كتائب القسام لن تنساهم وانها
بقائمه باسر هؤلاء الجنود من اجل اطلاق
سراحهم وتبادل اسرى على غرار ما حدث مع
شليط نتنياهو يعتقد انه هو الوحيد الذي
يفتح ويغلق هذا الباب ولكن نسي ان هناك
طرف اخر وهو كتائب القسام او القامه
الفلسطينيه التي ايضا لها ما تقدمه وما
تقوله اليوم عندما يتم الاعلان عن اربعه
بالاسماء والصور امام الجمهور الصهيوني
الاسرائيلي اعتقد ان المساله سوف تؤثر
داخليا على نتنياهو وربما يبدا يتحرك في
اتجاهات متعدده للوصول الى حل
ولكن بتقديرك لماذا لماذا كل هذا الانتظار
حتى يتم
الاعلان مؤخرا
سبق وان قدمت
حماس رساله افتراضيه واعتقد انها جاءت
ببعض المفاعيل داخل الكيان
الصهيوني هناك ظروف ربما امنيه نحن لا
نعلمها القسام
يعلمها كي كي تبدا تن ثم جاء نتنياهو
ليعلن امام جمهوره بان لديه معلومات باتت
جديده حول جنوده الاسرى داخل قطاع غزه
وخرج القسامي يقول بان هذا الرجل يكذب
ولذلك هو قدم هذه الروايه الان اعتقد انه
لابد من العمل على تحريك هذا الملف داخل
الكيان داخل الاحتلال لدى نتنياهو ومن ثم
انا في ظني ان كتائب القسام جاهزه لاي
حوار غير مباشر من اجل تحقيق صفقه تبادل
جديده على ذكر هذه الاشاره الى
نتنياهو نتنياهو سيد محمود يزبك اشار الى
هذا التطور المهم كما سم ما بعض التقارير
الصحفيه ربطت كلام نتنياهو بزياره وفد
حماس الاخير الى مصر بمعنى مصر هي التي
اثارت هذا الموضوع مع عفه حماس وقد يكون
هذا الاعلان جزء من ترتيب ما جرى مع
الجهات
المصريه هذا صحيح ممكن جدا انه يعني هذه
الزياره الاخيره لحماس ممثلين عن حماس
لمصر هي جاءت ضمن هذا الاطار من اجل بحث
هذه القضيه التي اخذت يعني الان تتفاعل
لكن انا اريد ان اذكر ان قبل عده اشهر كان
هنالك ظهور لعائله اسرائيليه معينه في
الصحافه الاسرائيليه في التلفزيون
الاسرائيلي
طالبت بالسؤال عن مصير ابنها وفي تلك
الفتره على ما ما حصل هو انه عمليا يعني
الصحافه الاسرائيليه والاعلام الاسرائيلي
تعامل مع نتنياهو ب
يعني بنعومه كبيره بانه من مصلحه هذا
الاسرائيلي عدم الخوض علنيا في القضيه
لانه الخوض علنيا في القضيه اعلاميا سيؤدي
سلبا سيؤثر سلبا على هذا الشخص والان على
ما يبدو وحتى هذا المساء يعني وبعد اعلان
حماس واعلان الصور الصور التي اظهرها حماس
حتى هذه الساعه لم تتفاعل وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تفاعل كبير مع القضيه قل قد
يكون هذا بسبب انه اليوم هو يوم السبت
وانت تعلم انه يوم السبت هو يوم العقله
الرسميه والدينيه ولكن من المنتظر انه
خلال الايام القادمه قد يحصل تفاعل ما
لانه السؤال لا يمكن ان يبقى تحت الطاوله
في المجتمع الاسرائيلي وخاصه انه
نتنياهو تحدث بانه هذه قضيه يعني فيها بعض
التطورات والان حماس تقول انه لم يكن
هنالك اي تطور او اي حديث بمعنى انه
نتنياهو يعني يتحدث اعلاميا حديثا كاذبا
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي وهذا مما سيضع الاعلام
الاسرائيلي الصحافه الاسرائيليه في مركز
الحدث وتسال السؤال هل حقيقه نتنياهو يقدم
تقريرا ش شفافا للمجتمع الاسرائيلي عما
يدور او انه يعني يختبئ من وراء هذه
القضيه ولا يريد اثارتها والان هي الملعب
الطابه الان الكره الان باعتقادي اكثر ليس
لد له نفسه ولكن لدى الاعلام الاسرائيلي
هل سيكون الاعلام الاسرائيلي متعاون مع مع
نتنياهو لاسكات هذه القضيه وجعلها قضيه
ثانويه ام انه سنرى منذ منتصف هذه الليله
ومن ومن صباح الغد يعني تفاعلا اعلاميا
ليبدا حمله الضغط على نتنياهو ليخرج
نتنياهو من جديد الى الاعلام ويتحدث عن
هذه القضيه لانه يعني درس شليت على ما
يبدو استطاع ان يستفيد منه نتنياهو
بالنهايه استفاده كبيره
بانه حينما كان هنالك ضغط جماهيري على
نتنياهو هذا الضغط الجماهيري ادى الى
تحرير عدد كبير من الاسرى الفلسطينيين
وهذا كان كانه بين كوسين اقتباس مضر
بالمجتمع الاسرائيلي ولذلك حا قب في
انتظار هذا التفاعل دكتور يسبك في انتظار
اضاع هذا هذا التفاعل ماذا عن التفاعل في
في في رام الله السيد هاني المصري خاصه
وان عاده ما يتم التعاطي مع هذا الموضوع
بكثير من الحذر وربما التوجس في في رام
الله بحكم سبقه شليط وما اثارته من من
جدل قبل ان اجيب عن هذا السؤال اسمح لي ان
احاول ان افسر لماذا التاخير في تفعيل هذا
الملف سواء من قبل اسرائيل او من قبل حركه
حماس اسرائيل حاولت في البدايه ولفتره
قريبه ان توحي بانها غير مكترث اطلاقا
بالمفقودين وانها لن تقدم اي مقابل مقابل
الافراج عن جسس كما تقول وعن اثنين من
المختلين
عقليا ولذلك اهملت هذا الموضوع كليا كنوع
من الضغط يعني على حركه حماس ودفعها
لتقديم معلومات ودفعها لتقديم مواقف مرونه
تسمح باتمام صفقه مريحه لاسرائيل مستفيده
من التجارب السابقه خاصه صفقه شاليت التي
استطاعت فيها يعني المقاومه الفلسطينيه ان
ان تفرج عن اعداد كبيره من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين وحماس حتى الان وكتائب القسام
تحديدا تحلت بضبط النفس ولم تبدي اي حراكا
وتحركت اخيرا عندما اعلن نتنياهو بان هناك
تطور مهم في هذا الملف ل تكذيب نتنياهو
واثاره الامر وتفعيله داخل اسرائيل لان
الوقت يبدو الان ملائم اكثر من الفتره
السابقه هذا بالنسبه للموضوع الثالث الذكر
اما بالنسبه عن ردود الفعل في رام الله
فبالتاكيد يعني هناك شعور مختلط يعني في
رام الله اي فلسطيني واي جناح فلسطيني
مهما كان يهمه ان يكون لدى الفلسطينيين
ورقه تساعدهم على اطلاق صراح الاسرى من
جهه ثانيه بالتاكيد هناك نوع من الحساسيه
او من التنافس او من ال غيره لان يعني
حماس من خلال امساكها باسرى يعني يمكن ان
تحقق نقاط لصالحها في ظل حاله الانقسام
الاسود التي تمر بها الساحه الفلسطينيه
وخاصه ان هناك
مقاربتين هناك بعض التقاطع بينهما ولكن
هناك فوارق كبيره لا تزال بينهما بين من
يركز على ارسال رسائل الاعتدال ورسائل
السلام في وقت لا يوجد فيه شريك فلسطين
اسرائيلي في وقت اسرائيل تتجه اكثر واكثر
نحو التطرف واحيت يعني خطه اسرائيل الكبرى
وازالت ماسمي الخط الاخضر وتحاول يعني ان
تقطع الطريق على اي امكانيه لاي تسويه على
اي امكانيه للاستجابه لاي حق من الحقوق
الفلسطينيه مما يوجب على الفلسطينيين ردا
مختلفا عن الرد الذي يعني يقدموه حتى الان
في ظل استمرار الانقسام وفي استمرار
التردد باتباع مسارات ومقاربات جديده
مختلفه كليا عن المسارات التي اتبعت سابقا
نعم نريد ان نعرف بعد الفاصل تفاعل هذه
القضيه من زاويه تاثيرها المحتمل على
حكومه نتنياهو لنا عوده بعد فاصل نرجو ان
تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها كشف حماس عن وجود
اسرائيليين لديها وتفاعلات ذلك في اسرائيل
خاصه لجهه تاثيره على حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو سيد مصطفى
صواف كتائب القسام اشارت الى نتنياهو
واعتبرت بانه لا يصارح شعبه بالحقيقه وبعض
ردود الفعل الاسرائيليه الاوليه اعتبرت
ذلك نوع من تاليب حماس للراي العام
الاسرائيلي ضد نتنياهو هل هذا جزء من
حسابات كتائب القص بتقديرك في هذه
القضيه نعم انا اعتقد ان جزء من هذه
الرساله هو تحريك الشارع الاسرائيلي
باتجاه الضغط على نتنياهو كما حدث ذلك في
اسر شاليط فلذلك المجتمع او المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين يتاثرون كثيرا بحركه المجتمع
خاصه اذا علمنا ان هناك استطلاعات رائل
تقول بان شعبيه نتنياهو في انخفاض فل ذلك
فتره مناسبه او لحظه مناسبه استغلالها حتى
يدرك نتنياهو بانه في خطر بمعنى ان هناك
ضغط حيكون من الشارع الاسرائيلي باتجاه
معرفه مصير هؤلاء الجنود هل هم احياء هل
هم اموات ماذا سيكون الحل هذه مسائل طبعا
يتابعها اهالي الجنود الاسرى ويتابعها
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بشكل عام حتى على
المستوى العسكري هناك ايضا متابعه في هذا
الامر فلذلك هذه هي احدى ادوات التي يمكن
ان تستخدمها حركه حماس وكتائب القسام في
تفعيل هذا الموضوع وعدم ابقائه مغلق بهذه
الطريقه التي يريدها نتنياهو فلذلك هم
استخدموا اكثر من رساله في هذا الاتجاه من
اجل الضغط على نتنياهو والمجتمع
الاسرائيلي بشكل عام نعم الدكتور محمود
يزبك قبل قليل اشرت الى ان ردود الفعل
الاسرائيلي لحد الان مازالت ضعيفه او او
باهته باعتبار عطله
السبت هل تعتقد بان جزء من ما يمكن ان
يثار الان هو ان نتنياهو سيجد نفسه في
مازق لانه لا يريد ان يتعرض لامتحان قاسي
مثل امتحان شليط بغض النظر هؤلاء سيعودون
امواتا ام هم احيا ك
كاسرى نعم يعني اولا هذا يتعلق عمليا
بالعائلات نفسها عائلات الاسرائيليين
محجوزين في في قطاع غزه اذا كانت هذه
العائلات تتحرك و وان اعتقد يعني بعد
الاعلان الجديد لحماس ستبدا هذه العائلات
بسؤال بالسؤال هل نتنياهو كاذب ام صادق
معنا لانه هنالك في تضارب كبير ما بين ما
قاله نتنه وبين ما قالته حماس وبين ما
تعرفه العائلات التي نحن لا نعرفه الان
هنا السؤال يعني عائله شليت والدرس الذي
تعلمناه منها انه هي استطاعت ان تحصل على
دعم لجمعيات مجتمع مدني اسرائيلي وهذه
بالتالي بدات تجعل القضيه يعني تتدحرج
السؤال هنا هل هذه العائلات على استعداد
ان تاخذ دورا مشابها لما قامت به عائله
شليت ومن ثم تجعل الاعلام الاسرائيلي
يتعاون معها للضغط على نتنياهو يعني هنا
هذا هذان العاملان هم عاملان اساسيان في
هذه القضيه لانه نتنياهو يريد ان يهرب من
القضيه قدر المستطاع السؤال انه هل تستطيع
وسائل الاعلام السكوت والتعاون مع تامر
اذا اردت بين قوسين اقتباس مع نتنياهو ضد
العائلات الاسرائيليه التي ابنائها يعني
يخدم بالجيش الاسرائيلي هذه نقطه تحول
كبيره جدا ستكون في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
اذا ما حصل انه العائلات التي ابنائها
يخدموا بالجيش الاسرائيلي تتعرض لمثل هذه
الاهانه والمهانه بانه نتنياهو يكذب بينما
بالحقيقه الاوضاع هي تختلف عما يقوله رئيس
الحكومه في هذه الظروف وكانه رئيس الحكومه
يقول للمجتمع الاسرائيلي انا صادق والان
يظهر يعني عارن جدا على انه يكذب ولذلك
انا بانتظار الايام القادمه هل الصحافه
الاسرائيليه هي حسب ما قالت عن نفسها
بالماضي انها هي صحافه مسؤوله وهي عمليا
سلطه رابعه في الدوله الاسرائيليه ام انها
هي مجرد عامل مساعد ل نتنياهو يتامر على
عائلات هؤلاء لمصلحه نتنياهو هذا امتحان
كبير جدا ليس فقط نتنياهو ب لكل مؤسسه
الاعلاميه الاسرائليه اذا ما وجد الدكتور
يزبك نتنياهو نفسه في مازق جديد هل هذا
السيد هاني المصري هل هذا يمكن ان يؤخذ
بعين الاعتبار في علاقه
السلطه باسرائيل لانه ان ان
يصبح وضع نتنياهو وضعا غير مريح بعد كل
هذه الاشهر والسنوات من الجمود يمكن ان
يعطي نوع من الحركيه للموقف الفلسطيني في
المرحله المقبله هل هذا
وارد بصراحه وبكل وضو غير وارد لان
التغييرات التي حدثت في اسرائيل منذ عام
2000 بشكل عام ومنذ عام 2009 بشكل خاص
يعني اوصلت اسرائيل لما يطلق عليه البعض
الجمهوريه الثالثه حيث اصبحت تنافس في
اسرائيل بين اليمين واليمين الاكثر تطرفا
ولم يعد هناك اي يسار حقيقي جدي له وزن
يؤبه له وبالتالي لا يوجد ما يدفع يعني
نتنياهو على اجراء تغييرات جوهريه يمكن
الحديث عن تسهيلات ولكن لا يمكن الحديث عن
تغيير يسمح مثلا بافق سياسي يسمح بعمليه
سياسيه جاده ولكن كل ما هو يمكن ان محاوله
اقناع السلطه للتقدم لمفاوضات من اجل
المفاوضات حتى يتم قطع الطريق على اي
مبادرات دوليه او على اي خيارات فلسطينيه
يجري البحث فيها ويشتد المطال بها حول
ضروره اعتماد خيارات اخرى غير الخيارات
التي اعتمدت خيارات تركز على جعل الاحتلال
مكلفا لاسرائيل على التركيز على تغيير
موازين القوى وليس انتظار الغيس من الخارج
لن ياتي يعني الانقاذ من السماء وانما يجب
ان يصنعه الفلسطينيون اولا وبعد ذلك
يستطيعوا ان يوظفوا اي تاييد عربي او دولي
يمكن ان يحصل ولكن النقطه الاولى التحرك
الاول يجب ان يكون هنا من الفلسطينيين
والوضع الفلسطيني في حاله من التيه في
حاله من فقدان الخيارات والبدائل في
استخدام الخيارات الجديده كتكتيك وليس
كاستراتيجيه وبالتالي لا تعطي مفعولها
الذي كان يمكن ان تعطيه لو كان هناك رسائل
حقيقيه من الجانب الفلسطيني بان مسار
اوسلو ومسار المفاوضات الثنائيه اقفل
نهائيا ولن يتم العوده له على العكس من
ذلك يتم اطلاق يعني رسائل كما لاحظنا في
الايام الاخيره بان السلطه ملتزمه
بالتنسيق الامني رغم انها قررت منذ اكثر
من عام بالمجلس المركزي واكدت هذه
القرارات اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه تحرير
بضروره اعاده النظر بالعلاقه كليا
بالاحتلال حتى تصبح علاقه مع احتلال وليس
علاقه مع شريك سلام وبالتالي اعاده النظر
بكل الالتزامات
السياسيه والامنيه والاقتصاديه بدلا من
ذلك نلاحظ اعاده انتاج لهذه المسيره
باشكال اخرى رغم ان اسرائيل لم تعد منذ
فتره طويله ملتزمه باتفاق اوسلو واتفاق
اوسلو حي فقط على الجانب الفلسطيني حيث
الاعتراف باسرائيل وحيث التنسيق الامني
والتبعيه الاقتصاديه نعم سيد مصري صفقه
شريط عندما تمت وهنا انهي مع السيد مصطفى
صواف عندما تمت صفقه شليط اعتبرت صفقه
مؤلمه الى درجه ان اسرائيل كانت قررت الا
تتعرض مره اخرى الامتحان بنفس القسوه هل
بتقديرك الان كتائب القسام وحركه حماس
تؤمن بان يمكن لها مره اخرى ان تعقد صفقه
ربما اكثر ايلاما مع اسرائيل في الاشهر
المقبله نعم هذا ممكن خاصه لو عدنا الى
الوراء وصفقه شالي كان هناك قرارا لدى
الجانب الاسرائيلي بعدم الافراج عن
السجناء الفلسطينيين الاسرى داخل سجن
الاحتلال التي اطلق عليهم بين قوسين الايد
الملطخه بالدماء هذا الموضوع لم يعد قائما
في ذلك الوقت وتم تنفيذ الصفقه واعتقد ان
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ونتنياهو تحديدا في
هذه الظروف هو بحاجه لشيئ ما يتحرك من
خلاله كي يعيد عمليه التوازن لحزب اللكود
وله في اي انتخابات قادمه فلذلك سوف يقدم
على الغاء كل القرارات التي صدرت سواء من
الكنيست او من الحكومه حول تحريم اجراء اي
صفقه مع المقاومه
وسيقوم بذلك وربما بعضنا استمع الى حديث
نتنياهو مع ميركل حول طلبه منها بالتدخل
من اجل معرفه مصير هؤلاء الجنود معنى ذلك
ان هذا الملاف له مكانه لدى نتنياهو وهو
يريد ان ينهيه فلذلك سيتم تجاوز كثير من
القوانين التي وضعت وستنفذ صفقه قادمه
لانه لا يمكن اطلاق سراح هؤلاء او عودتهم
الى ذويهم دون ان يكون هناك صفقه وكما
قالت القسام ان اي معلوم مجرد معلومه لابد
ان يكون هناك ثمن فكيف لو كان هناك اطلاق
سراح ن شكرا شكرا لك سيد مصطفى صواف
الكاتب والبحث السياسي من غزه شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من رام الله هاني المصري مدير مركز
مسارات لابحاث السياسات وضيفنا من الناصره
الدكتور محمود يزبك استاذ الدراسات الشرق
اوسطيه في جامعه حيفا في امان
[موسيقى]
الله